[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday
hands face space they lectured us day
after day well the hands and face of
former health secretary matt hancock
were pretty active in the video we saw
last week but there wasn't much space at
all between him and his paid advisor
and that in the end is why he had to go
those of us who make these rules
have got to stick by them and that's why
i have got to resign he said
but only it seems after fellow ministers
and mps told him that he'd become
toxic last night he departed for a
period of political self-isolation
former chancellor sajid javid steps back
into the cabinet as the new health
secretary
in the next hour we'll be talking about
what the resignation means for the
credibility of the government
the leadership of the nhs and the
country as we emerge from the most
serious public health crisis
of the past 100 years
northern ireland secretary brandon lewis
will be talking about matt hancock's
dramatic exit from department of health
labour's lucy powell tells us why she
thinks mr hancock should have been
sacked
before he got the chance to walk we'll
be speaking to the chair of the british
medical association chart not paul about
the challenges facing the new health
secretary
and asking one of britain's leading
public health experts linda bold whether
the public can be expected to follow the
rules
when ministers don't and finally we've
got a man who's been there and done it
former health secretary alan johnson
but first let's get the view from the
cabinet i'm joined by the northern
ireland secretary brandon
lewis
good morning mr lewis why did it take
matt hancock two days to be dragged
kicking and screaming from the
department of health
well i don't think that's a fair
description trevor i'm gonna have to
disagree with you
for the first part there look i think
quite rightly matt has been focused
all through this pier the last year and
a half or more that we've been all
dealing with this
the dreadful situation with the pandemic
and focused on delivering for people
he wanted to stay focused on that the
government want to stay focused
we've got a strong team of the
department of health who have got that
knowledge that experience
to take that forward but look matt in
his own letter i think said
and ultimately he's he's the right he's
made i think probably the right judgment
in the sense that he doesn't want
this situation around himself to
distract from that key focus and the key
work for government
which is to deliver for people on the
pandemic and as we are coming out of the
pandemic
the secretary of state for health
formally
spent much of the past year telling the
rest of us how to
live our private lives he shamed people
neil ferguson the scientist for example
who broke the rules and yet he then
spent
two days telling everyone that it was
vital for him to stay in office and that
they shouldn't uh judge him on the basis
of
his private life he doesn't get it does
he
well as matt himself said he apologized
for what he had done he apologized for
breaching the the guidelines we've all
got to do our bit absolutely he's been
right all the way along we've all got to
do our bit to follow the guidelines
that helps keep not just ourselves and
our friends and our families but our
wider community safer but
as matt said in his letter yesterday he
didn't want his own situation and
what he had done in terms of breaching
the guidelines in his private life
situation to distract from the important
work that we've all got to focus on i
know saji javi will be focused on
which is taking our country forward
through the next stage of the pandemic
and as we are rolling
out of the challenges of the pandemic as
we continue the vaccine rolled out
there's been
a phenomenal success and something matt
and his team should be rightly proud of
yeah but this wasn't he forgot his mask
when he went into a shop
this was something quite different he
carried on a relationship fair enough
but in that relationship he did things
that he was telling
the rest of us that we may not do
and as matt said in his resignation
letter you know this is one of the
reasons why he took the decision
uh having given it some thought i think
he took the decision as he said that
uh it was right for him to not be a
continual distraction what he did was
wrong that's why he apologized
and he wants the country to have the
ability to focus on dealing with the
pandemic and as i say this
next steps as we are coming out of the
pandemic i think it's a credit to matt
that his
first thought is around making sure the
country and the government can continue
to do the work we need to do
as we are moving out of the kovy
pandemic
but mr lewis look let's get to
the root of this anybody can make a
mistake
but both mr hancock and mr johnson for
48 hours
carried on as though it was a minor slip
nothing uh was too wrong
and there is a sense this morning that
matt hancock
resigned not really because what he
thought what he had done was wrong was
but
but because everybody else is saying
it's
wrong and the prime minister doesn't
quite
in his letter say uh matt what you did
was wrong and embarrassing in fact he
uses the word the phrase you should be
proud are matt hancock and boris johnson
the only people in the country who can't
see why he
the real reason he had to go well
against
trevor i'm afraid i disagree with the
premise that you're coming from i think
it's right that matt
and his entire team there's a really
good team of department health with um
nadine sahib obviously in this
phenomenal vaccine role out ed argher
james bethel the entire team there
nadine doris
and joe as well churchill taking forward
the work
to make sure the country is able to deal
with the pandemic and i think matt
should be proud of what he has seen at
the hill so it's not just dealing with a
pandemic which has been something
none of us would have found an easy
project over the last year and a half
and he's done that with
clear focus and vigor to deliver for
people across the country and the
vaccine rolled out but the technology
improvements in the nhs
the work to make gps more accessible and
to be ready
as we're coming out of the kovy pandemic
i do think
it was right the prime minister matt
were focused even in the last couple of
days
on making sure that experience that
knowledge that has been gained through
the last year and a half or so
of dealing with the pandemic was there
to be able to focus on the pandemic
i don't think that is in any
contradiction at all to matt
after day or so taking that opportunity
to look at the situation
and to reflect and decide that his
position was distracting from the work
as we come out of the pandemic and i
think
credit to matt that his focus is not
just on his family but on the wider
country in the best
interest of the uk let me try this
another way
um if something like this had taken
place
in your department the northern ireland
department
involving one of your junior ministers
and a person working for the department
i want you to tell me that it would take
you 48 hours
to decide that something had to be done
and that actually
you like the prime minister wouldn't say
to that
junior minister you gotta go
well the reason i never ever in any
interviews over the years i've been
talking to colleagues and yourself
trevor on a range of interviews i never
get into the hypotheticals is because
every situation
you have to consider and even yeah but
even in this situation trevor you've got
to look at the unique circumstances of a
situation like the pandemic
with the knowledge and the focus and the
experience that matt had had
leading the department through the
pandemic and the desire to keep the
focus on
how we use that expertise and that
knowledge to take the team forward and
the country forward as i say i think
matt
has made the right decision i think he's
done it with the best interests of
his family in the united kingdom at the
forefront and credit to him for that
because
he didn't want his situation to distract
from things you've got to look at these
situations
as they develop in real time with the
specific knowledge
of that particular situation so you
can't do hypotheticals across different
areas
our focus for the government i know
sanji javi's focus working with the
brilliant team at the department of
health
will be on moving forward the next steps
through and out of this pandemic
all right well let's leave matt hancock
himself alone for the moment and talk
about
the government itself because as you say
the government's got to take this
forward
now to take it forward
the government has to retain its
authority and know that people are going
to listen to it
now let me put this to you what it might
sound like to the person in the street
is cummings and barnard castle
hypocrisy matt hancock and some blokinos
gets ppe contracts cronyism carrying the
wallpaper in number 10
profligacy and now snogging videos from
the guy who tells you you can't hug your
gran
one rule for us and one for them uh are
you
about to squander all of the credit that
you have built up as a government
in the successful vaccine rollout
oh well actually as i said i think the
vaccine model has been a phenomenal
success that's a credit to the deans of
harvey matt hancock himself
and the entire team at the health
service you've told me that five times
no we're going to be focused on
continuing to roll out the vaccines
we've got 83 percent of the public had
that first dose now
over 60 percent had the second dose and
half of under 30s as well which is
brilliant but we need to continue
to focus on that and i think ultimately
what the public wants us focused on
what my residency in great yarmouth and
people i talk to people in northern
ireland wants us focused on
is getting on with the job of government
making sure that we can continue to
deliver on that vaccine rollout
keep it going keep moving out of the
pandemic build back better and be ready
for the opportunities that lay ahead for
the united kingdom
mr lewis i i wouldn't normally do
something like this but um i want to
put a private personal question i guess
in a way to you
over the past two days every cabinet
minister including you
has come out to essentially defend
the prime minister and matt hancock
the pictures that we saw were of an
encounter on may the 6th
on may 11th my family buried my daughter
who had died not of kobe but during the
lockdown
300 of our family and friends turned up
online
but most of them were not allowed to be
at the graveside
even though it was in the open air
because of the rule of
thirty because of the instruction
by mr hancock now the next time one of
you tells me
what to do in my private life explain to
me
why i shouldn't just tell you where to
get off
well i i absolutely accept and
understand the frustration
even the anger that people have having
been through the situations they've been
through look
as you say to other people across the
country i've lost friends as funerals
i've not been able to go to
over the last period that is such a
tragic situation for any of us to be in
and that's
i have to say why it's so important all
of us do what we can to
keep ourselves our families our friends
our wider community
safe it's also why but what matt did was
wrong he
acknowledged that's why he apologized
immediately for his baby and
acknowledged what he did was wrong
and it's ultimately why he's taken the
decision that his position was untenable
and distracting from the wider work that
we've all got to do
to move forward in the pandemic and out
of the pandemic there's no getting away
from that and i think that's why matt
ultimate made the decision he did as i
say i think in doing that
he's put his family and indeed all of us
across the uk first because he wants to
focus
as the pm does as we all do to be on
getting out of this pandemic
in the best possible way and as quickly
as we can okay i'm going to have
one last attempt does any of you
understand
the fact that it took two days to get it
to this point
feels to everybody who is not you
like he only only stepped down
because everybody else was shouting at
him
not because he or the prime minister
actually understood what this
feels like to everybody else
well as i said trevor earlier on i'm
afraid i don't disagree with the premise
you set out i think the prime minister
of matt and i think people will
see that the prime minister and matt
hancock were focused on dealing with the
pandemic that's what they saw as the
prime theme matt accepted what he did
was wrong and apologize for that
and i think credit to matt that he's
looked at it again on reflection and
taking the view that his position
was distracting from that wider piece
work he wants like we all want
our focus to be on dealing with the
pandemic and the next stages as we come
out of that
and that's only where all of the
government's focus will be and sagi
javid and the team of the health
department will be looking forward
to how we develop out of the pandemic
from a health sense
as all of us will more widely as a
country as we build back better in the
future
all right we'll come to mr jarvis
challenges in a moment but um
before we do that i want to ask you
about the security
aspects of this you are well versed in
this area though of course this specific
issue will not be your responsibility um
we don't know exactly how anybody
came to be in possession of these
pictures
but presumably the government will be
undertaking an urgent security
review because how is it possible that
what goes on
in a minister's office or behind a
closed door
for a minister can be made public in
this way i mean
for matt hancock it was embarrassing i
think in your case
it could be lethal
uh well look trevor you're quite right
and i've seen some of the reports this
morning
outlining how different uh journalists
think that the tape may have got out
there that is sony mata i know the help
department health
will be looking into to understand
exactly how that
was recorded and how it got out of the
system it's something we need to get to
the bottom of as you say
quite rightly what happens in government
departments can be sensitive and
important
and it's but people need to have the
confidence that what is happening
in a government department is something
that allows government to be focused on
those core issues
and the sensitivity sometimes in a
security sense of those core issues so
yes i do know that is something the
department of health
will be taking forward as an internal
investigation we need to see let them
have the space to do that
to understand how this happening to
ensure this kind of situation
um can't happen again or across
government indeed it doesn't look good
though does it because um literally just
before i came on there i don't know if
you're aware of this
news broke that sensitive documents
uh about the defense
establishment and movements of uh our
warships were discovered at a
bus stop in kent by a member of the
public
uh yes no i am i'm aware of this uh as
well trevor and
as i say the as you rightly say it's
something that none of us want to see
shouldn't be able to happen
uh it was properly reported at the time
into the ministry of defense there's
obviously an internal investigation into
that situation as well
and we've got again i've got to wait and
allow the team to put the department of
defense to
ministry of defense to work through that
investigation to understand exactly how
this
managed to occur um mr javed
uh i gather we'll be speaking to the
press
later on this morning he's got a big
entry um completing the vaccine rollout
uh catching up with the backlog maybe
five million
uh patients unwinding the reforms
from a decade ago not to mention
uh social care the americans um have
this expression a hospital pass
which is when you throw the football to
somebody who's about to be
uh buried under three 200
ton opposition defenders um
is mr javed getting a hospital pass with
uh the department of health and social
care now
not at all i know the analogy my
football days may be a bit behind me and
i was probably one of those
larger defenders you refer to trevor but
we're very fortunate in our parties to
have such a great depth of talent and
having sadji javi with
such a phenomenal wide experience across
government leading key big departments
um coming back in means we've got
somebody who knows how to get things
done who knows how to
manage your mother department and he is
going to be working with what is a
phenomenal team at the department of
health
really strong ministers a team that's
worked so well together through the
pandemic to deliver for people across
the country in the most
challenging times that our health
service has ever seen and i know that
saggy will be
absolutely laser focused on making sure
that we're able to move forward in a
positive way
i suppose the prime minister reminded
him that he's not just secretary of
state for health
but also for social care um we
understood that there was going to be
the beginnings at least of a proposal
uh for social care emerging this week
will mr javid still tell us what the
government wants to do
on social care or is that going to be
delayed yet again
oh well the prime minister has outlined
that he will be coming forward with some
plans before the end of the year that
will be the focus of the department
health as i say the whole team helen
waitley and
garga the whole team working with uh
sanji javid who i as i say will be
somebody who is focused on
getting things done and delivering this
is a hugely we all know it's a very very
not just sensitive but a really
complicated area i used to be a local
myself there's obviously a huge
work across sajid has got great
experience of that from his time at
communities and local government and
understanding how that comes together
and delivering something that can really
work for people
in a way that's fair and gets the job
done so people have got that confidence
in older age to be able to look forward
so that is something we want to do by
the end of the year and i know sanji
will be focused on that
as much as he is on that wide range of
issues as we are developing out of the
kovi pandemic
mr lewis thank you very much indeed
thank you matt hancock threw in the
towel 36 hours after his
affair was exposed on the front page of
the sun
last night he released a video statement
explaining
why he felt he had to quit i've been to
see the prime minister to
resign as secretary of state for health
and social care
i understand the enormous sacrifices
that
everybody in this country has made that
you have made
and those of us who make these rules
have got to stick by them and that's why
i've got to resign
i want to thank people for their
incredible
sacrifices and what they've done
everybody working in the nhs
across social care everyone involved in
the
in the vaccine program and frankly
everybody in this country
who has risen to the challenges that
we've seen
over this past 18 months i'm very proud
of what we've done
to protect the nhs at the peak to
deliver that vaccine rollout from one of
the fastest in the world
and i look forward to supporting
the government and the prime minister
from the back benches
to make sure that we can get out of this
pandemic
we're so close to the end and then
build back better so that this country
can fulfill
its potential which is so great
and i will do that with all of my heart
the labour leader sir stomach has said
that matt hancock was right to resign
but the prime minister should have
sacked him why the party asked did boris
johnson say on friday that the matter
was closed
when it clearly wasn't i'm joined now by
labour's lucy powell
lucy powell matt hancock says he's sorry
he's let people down and he's gone
shouldn't that be the end of it
well i'm afraid this goes to the
judgment and the leadership of the prime
minister as well because
matt hancock yes it's good that he's now
gone but he should have gone
on friday and the prime minister should
have sacked him
and these are the difficult decisions of
leadership and
i'm afraid it feels to me like the prime
minister has a very
dangerous blind spot when it comes to
issues of integrity
and conduct in public life and that's a
really big problem
and it's even bigger problem when you're
in the middle of a pandemic and you're
asking the public
to also have integrity and conduct in
the way that they
go about with their own lives
are you going to oppose the um
severance uh payment that mr to which mr
hancock is
statutorily entitled i think it comes
out at something like 18 000 pounds
well i think most of your viewers would
be appalled to think
that um there's going to be a severance
payment to
matt hancock in this circumstance let's
not forget
he as the health secretary was the guy
who recommended that our nhs
workers after the year that they've just
had in this pandemic on the front line
who have worked flat out who are now on
their knees
he recommended that they in effect had a
pay cut
and i think to find out that he's now
going to get
thousands of pounds as some kind of
severance redundancy payment
for frankly uh being caught on the job
while he was on the job
you know i think would be uh pretty
disgusting to most people
and we will certainly be calling that
out and and asking the prime minister
not to give him that well we don't know
whether mr hancock wants to claim it or
not
so to be fair um it's at the moment
hypothetical but
to get an idea of how far you want to
press this
when professor neil ferguson
conducted an extramarital affair mr
hancock
was one of his most vociferous critics
and actually he
said that um he supported the call for a
police inquiry
um do you think that the police should
look into mr hancock's
uh behavior
sorry i couldn't hear that very well
could you just say that again there's
something about
this of course of course i'm trying to
work out how far labour wants to push
this
when neil ferguson ran into
trouble mr hancock supported a call for
a police inquiry
and i'm just wondering whether labour
would do the same in this situation
well my colleague fleur anderson has
referred this to
uh the police because she wants to know
we want to know
whether the police will be looking at
whether matt hancock did
break the law in um in his actions
at the time you'll remember uh when this
video was was taken we were all told
that we could only have close contact
with those that we were
in a bubble with they were our bubble
and that was the only people we could
have close contact with that was the law
at the time yet it now turns out that
matt hancock was actually in two bubbles
at the same time
unbeknown to other people uh in that
bubble and that is how
infection spread so yes there are
serious issues here which need further
investigation and we will be
looking at those because of course you
know matt hancock was the first to say
that
neil ferguson and others should have
resigned when they broke the rules and
that other people
needed to abide by them so you can't
have the rule maker
also being the rule breaker people want
to know there's accountability in that
um the government obviously wants to
limit
this to an issue of one individual's
conduct
but i think from what labor leaders have
been saying
you think that this is endemic in
government and i just want to
uh pick up on a couple of the points
that you've made you've said that um
mrs colladangelo is an old university
friend of
mr hancock's appointed as a
non-executive at
the department of health but of course
at the point was cleared
by the permanent secretary department of
health
um why go after them on that basis
well look i think there are widespread
there seem to be widespread issues here
as i say the prime minister seems to
have a really dangerous
blind spot when it comes to to these
issues we now also find
out that matt hancock was using his own
private
uh gmail account to undertake
effectively negotiations and discussions
about
very large nhs contracts
that comes on top of other questions
relating to michael gove pretty patel
and others about the the handing out of
government contracts and so
yes there are some very serious issues
here that seem to cut across
the whole of government about how
government contracts
uh government pay paid for jobs are
being handed out and whether they're
being done
in accordance with those nolan
principles of public life and in
accordance with
the ministerial code of conduct which
i'm afraid the prime minister seems to
uh you know disregard whenever it suits
him it's not really worth the paper it's
written on at the moment
and so yes we will be pursuing those
wider issues and there are there are
those wider issues across government
it is of course the role of the
opposition to point out the government's
failings to scrutinize it to point out
the issues of cronyism chamocracy all
that kind of thing
but um what would you do
to change that i mean presumably if
you're making the case that this is
characteristic of the whole government
and
not joff just a couple of one-off
problems
there is something systemic that has to
be tackled here so
what is that and what would labor
actually do about it
well i think it does speak to who does
the conservative party
represent here in whose interests are
they governing
are they governing in the interests of a
lot of their
wealthy donors their mates in in
business looking to
to make a fast book off the the public
sector or are they governing
in the interests of ordinary working
people who are trying to get by in this
country who need decent pay
decent housing and decent jobs and
it feels to me time and time again that
this conservative party i'm afraid
are governing in the interests of their
wealthy
friends and that's when it gets found
out so
yes it's it's not just about your
processes and whether you've got strong
leadership and
you know i absolutely believe that
kstarma would have sacked matt hancock
or
if it had been any one of us in this
situation on the spot
and how you deal with them but it's also
about in whose interests
are you governing in whose interests are
you a politician
and that's where the labour party and
the conservative party
you really have quite a big uh
difference i think
you say that kirst alma would have done
this differently and been decisive and
all that
but look you're confronted with the
government against whom
you can and have made over many months
credible charges of hypocrisy
sleaze cronyism and sheer incompetence
yet you managed to lose a by-election in
a previously safe seat
last month you're in danger of losing
another one
this week and you're way behind in the
polls how can that
possibly be i mean how do you manage
that
well the by-election on thursday has not
happened yet
we've got a fantastic local candidate in
kim ledbetter
who is a very passionate local community
activist she's not really a politician
at all and
will be fighting for every vote on on
thursday so let's see what happens
uh there but of course you know in in a
pandemic
it's not a time of politics as usual um
people want to see the government
succeed we want to get back to
life as normal and we have to take a a
slightly different approach as as the
opposition people don't want to
uh just hear from us in terms of
opposition for opposition's sake they
want to see us being
constructive and and working uh where we
need to
working with the government to end this
pandemic so we can all move on and
we're emerging out of that i hope uh
soon
and um you know i think you'll hear a
lot more from labour over the coming
months
about how we'll deal with some of those
underlying issues that this pandemic has
exposed you know the gross
inequality in this country and health in
wealth and in our public services
one very one very quick last question if
i may um
sunday time this morning says that some
labor figures
are trying to persuade tony blair to
stand for
parliament uh again might there be some
labour hearts going
pitter-patter at the prospect of the
return of the old boss
uh i don't think so no um we've got a
very uh
good leader in case dahmer and we are
all
united uh behind him you know we've got
that
t-shirt we've watched that movie before
where we turn in us
on ourselves and and focus on on these
these other issues and that
movie doesn't end well for labour so we
are focused on being united
and getting behind uh kirst armour so
that we can
put forward that compelling radical big
offer to the country
that we need to do at the next election
lucy powell thank you very much indeed
thank you since the nhs was founded in
1948
the job of health secretary has been one
of the biggest in the government
but right now in the midst of a pandemic
it's probably fair to say it's bigger
than ever
and while the immediate crisis of
hospitals being overwhelmed
appears to have passed the long-term
consequences will take years to deal
with
more than 5 million people are now on
nhs
waiting lists i'm joined now by the
chair of the british medical association
dr chand
nag paul dr nagpul
do you think your members will accept
matt hancock's
apology at face value or will they
say that he's only stepping down because
he had no choice
i think what our members are saying is
that they are feeling
absolutely exhausted after 15 months of
this pandemic many
have worked flat out without breaks they
worked
during the lockdowns when at the
stay-at-home periods
busier than ever about four intense say
their mental health is worse than before
the pandemic significantly
uh you have about one in three saying
they are going to be retiring the next
year
about one in five saying they'll leave
the nhs or reduce their hours
and remember this is on the back of
about eight and a half thousand
unfilled uh doctor vacancies about 80
000
vacancies in the nhs that have been
unfilled now this comes at a time
when the new health secretary uh was
going to see a baptism of fire
he won't have the luxury of a phased
handover
he'll have to make every day count and
um we're facing as you've said
a record five plus million patients on
waiting lists
and that includes about 400 000 who've
been waiting more than
12 months and that's not to inc and that
doesn't include about
20 million patients who were not seen in
outpatient clinics last year
so we really do have not an issue of a
a backlog crisis of care because many of
those patients will become
more ill as time goes on many of them
have health conditions which if they're
not treated promptly
will become more serious and what he
will need to do is
manage that uh crisis in a way that that
delivers prioritization but also be
honest
with the public about the length of time
it's going to take and as a health
secretary as
a former chancellor he's going to need
to negotiate
the resources that the nhs needs the
government has not costed
for the several billions of pounds that
are going to be needed
to address this backlog so he'll have to
do that as well
we'll come to the issue of resources in
a moment but um
mr javid will be talking to the press
probably within the next hour or so
what's the most important thing you want
to hear from him this morning
well what i want to hear from him is one
that he understands
the workforce because the health service
cannot survive without its workforce he
needs to understand the pressures we
feel
he needs to understand the fact that we
need to have a proper rest
and to recover before the onslaught of
the uh recovery
of the backlog of care that's going to
need to be delivered and he needs to
value us
and he will have to also address uh the
issues around pay and
the uh derisory one percent uplift that
has you know uh distressed a lot of the
workforce
in terms of not feeling valued but the
other thing he's going to logistically
need to deliver on
is the vaccination program because we
are still in the midst of a pandemic
we have spiraling uh numbers of cases
now uh over
over eighteen thousand yesterday uh new
cases we are actually seeing
increases in hospitalization not at the
level of before
but it is impacting on hospitals uh at
the moment
and and he's going to have to get up to
speed and make sure that the adult
population
tens of millions of which have not yet
been vaccinated get vaccinated in the
coming weeks
it's a huge challenge let's let's take a
couple of those points
um the backlog other than saying he
recognizes how hard everybody's
worked the problems of morale
uh outlining the numbers involved in
what
does he have to do what do you want him
to say he's going to
do to fix that so what he needs to do
is first of all retain the workforce uh
he needs to
show he needs to he's need to speak to
the british medical association the
royal court
what signal what signal would convince
you that that's happening
okay well one would be to be honest with
the public of the scale of work so that
he doesn't just put arbitrary targets
that we just somehow can magic up
delivering care
and clear the backlog in the next few
months that just isn't going to happen
he needs to make sure that there are
issues such as rest facilities
40 of doctors say they don't even have a
place to rest
in hospital he needs to make sure that
we can take leave we can
uh recover and then that we have a
prioritization program
where those patients who need to be seen
first are seen first
and that he puts in place the logistics
to make that happen
he needs to also make sure that we are
valued both in terms of
uh the terms and conditions we work in
but also pay
and he needs to retain the workforce and
also i should mention
uh do much more with the retired
workforce who are willing to come and
help
the government did not avail of the
retired workforce last year
they need to do that now especially at
this critical time
that that's interesting because i was
going to say you know we want rest
we want recognition of the pressure that
people have been under
which sounds to me like you need more
doctors
like tomorrow but you can't train them
in less than seven years
so what uh him saying what i'm going to
do
is i'm going to pay and provide
incentives
for doctors to come out of retirement be
the sort of thing that you're looking
for
well you see i mean obviously retired
doctors can't do you know they've
retired but
large numbers have actually retired in
the last two years and so they can
certainly bring their skills
uh for example in terms of the huge
backlog they can be
uh looking at the prioritization of
patients they can actually be providing
a lot of the support by phone
uh and video consultations for in in
primary care for example
but you're absolutely right ultimately
we have been running a health service
that are tens of thousands of doctors
short and tens of thousands of nurses
short
and that recruitment won't be able to be
delivered immediately
but obviously what he has to commit to
is a training program that delivers that
in the years to come the other thing
that i'd like to say
is that we also have large numbers of
doctors who come from overseas
to the uk and at the moment there are
considerable hurdles and obstacles
that are preventing them coming here and
they're going to other nations
uh we need to make sure that as a as as
a country
we're we're offering those doctors who
want to come and work here
the ability to do so and to not be uh
and to value
uh their contribution to the nhs many
come here for training because they need
postgraduate exam
qualifications from centers of
excellence in the uk and at the moment
many are being deterred from coming
due to certain bureaucratic obstacles
that need to be addressed
doctor mike pogba is clear more
immigrant doctors
more doctors who may have retired to who
can help perhaps do
things um you talked about pay the bma
has been at war with every health
secretary
since the inception of the nhs ken clark
once said that you've got to find a
concession to give the bma at least
once a year and um nye bevan who founded
the
uh the nhs said uh he
he was only able to do it by stuffing
doctor's mouth
with gold um is all of this
more to do with doctors wanting more
rather than patients needing more
no i i would absolutely refute that and
in fact i don't think this is actually
an issue about doctors per se
if you look at the healthcare workforce
you know all of the healthcare workforce
feel uh absolutely uh exhausted they
have actually delivered during the most
testing period the nhs has faced
since its inception they've gone into
work exposed themselves
to a deadly virus back in last march and
april
when we didn't even have enough ppe uh
i think about 800 or 900 healthcare
workers have died many have fallen
seriously ill and large numbers of
course have come from
doctors and nurses from overseas and
from ethnic minorities i actually don't
think
this is an issue about any one sector of
the nhs the entire workforce
actually does deserve recognition for
its efforts
uh and it does deserve uh proper terms
conditions
and pay to reflect that uh so i don't
think this is about
about politics at all this is about fair
recognition
dr mcpaul thank you very much thank you
one of the one of the features of this
pandemic has been people who make the
rules for everyone else
breaking them it was a trend started
back in april last year when scotland's
chief medical officer
had to resign for going to her holiday
home during lockdown
and now a humiliated matt hancock has
quit because
he was kissing his aide in the
department of health while the public
were banned from hugging
their loved ones professor linda bald is
a public health expert and a behavioral
scientist
um professor ball let's just start with
the situation this week
um kate number cases of delta
up 46 percent scotland recorded its
highest
number in a single day um should we
really seriously be thinking about
lifting restrictions on july 19th
well i think you know as everybody said
before it should be data
not dates and uh there are two things to
say
the rising cases both from the test
positivity
people coming forward from it for a test
and also the reactant
and the ons infection service which are
all pointing in the same direction do so
show a substantial rise and i think
that's a cause for concern
where there is more positive news though
is that
the proportion of people who are going
into hospital as you know trevor
as a proportion of cases is far far
lower for example at the beginning of
this year it might have been 10 to 15
percent of people who would end up in
hospital now it's about
5 so if that trend continues and the
hospital numbers despite what dr nagpal
was saying some hospitals are under
pressure
don't go up exponentially then i think
the government is under a lot of
pressure to stick with that date but all
the researchers and the clinicians will
see
will be saying let's make sure that the
data is going in the right direction
you know a week or two before then
before we can say we're proceeding
i want to come back to ask you about the
behavioral science implications
of the hancock affair in a moment but
there is a behavioral issue here isn't
there
the more that we put the july 19th date
up in
lights the harder it is for a government
not to do it or to do something
that is in some way a variant of um
what it's of people's expectations
is this date thing becoming a problem i
think the date thing
is a problem and there's a couple of
reasons for that and the first thing is
that
when you sort of set a date like that
and people are looking forward to it
it's a bit like going on holiday you do
start to relax a bit before you go on
holiday you're anticipating it you're
looking forward to it
and you also i think people are thinking
well if we've got that date that means
we're almost back to normal so if we're
almost back to normal i might as well do
those things now and you can see that
from the ons social impacts survey that
people's
compliance with distancing has declined
their contacts have gone up of course
but more than we might have thought and
also from the ucl covered social study
you can see
compliance declining so i think that is
a risk the other
issue with dates of course is that it's
the politics of it trevor isn't it
all these sectors that have to plan very
legitimately
and if the dates then change they will
be furious as we've already seen
you know even to the extent of taking
the government to court so it's a very
very tricky thing and that's why i think
you know it should be more communicated
as a tentative date to aim for but it
might change
and governments are not very good at
communicating that uncertainty
well of course the magic bullet in all
of this is vaccination uh isn't it
what what um what level of
uh double vaccination would you be
comfortable
with for a re-opening um people
talked at one point about 60 percent now
i think they're talking about 83
what what do you think is the right sort
of level we should be looking at
so we're all hesitant to pin an exact
percentage on it because the
science doesn't necessarily support that
but it's very clear when you have a more
transmissible variant and you need to
minimize the reservoir of the population
that are still
able to pass the virus on and we can see
that that is largely younger people so
we need to vaccinate
more younger people keeping in mind that
people under around the age of 40 but in
their 40s
only about 4 and 10 of them have had the
second dose so far
so i think we're looking probably at
vaccination double doses of 80
ideally if we can get there and and if
you look internationally trevor israel
of course
had opened up and removed almost all
restrictions are now reimposing a few of
them primarily to space coverings
in indoor places until they can get
their vaccination rate which was higher
than ours
at an even higher level in the face of
delta so that's where we are at the
moment
but you know the vaccine program despite
concerns about supplies
is going well and final point for me on
this the data that many of us had seen
about hesitancy amongst young
people is not borne out by what we're
seeing in practice young people are very
keen
to get this vaccine the vast majority of
them um
you're not a politician so i'm not going
to draw you into
the shenanigans that i've been
discussing with others
however what we've learned in the last
year
is public sentiment uh has
a huge impact on the capacity
to deal with this thing so
behavioral science has seriously
mattered in the last
year now um professor steven reichert
who i think you'll know
said yesterday that the prime minister's
support for mr
hancock quote trashes all the advice
given by scientists about building trust
um are you with him on this yes i agree
with steve
and and as steve has also said hancock
lost
moral authority public trust and the
prime minister supporting him
even for a short period you know i mean
even a day is is a long time in politics
i think steve has also said
it was very unfortunate i mean mr
hancock has done the right thing i think
by resigning quick action makes a
difference
just to tell you briefly trevor about a
study that my colleagues at ucl did
around
what happened with dominic cummings of
course right that dragged on for ages
there was no
resignation and you can see that public
trust in the uk government was badly
affected by that in the period after the
event in may
and for the three weeks afterwards they
looked at that and compared it with
public trust in government in scotland
and wales in those p
in those citizens owned governments
didn't decline and also public's
trust in the nhs etc didn't decline so
it was a cummings effect in relation to
the uk government
so i think the problem there in the
behavioral message is
we can't have one rule for them and
another for us
that divides the country and if the
government is asking people to change
their behavior as they still are
and comply with public health guidelines
they need to do it themselves
and lead by example so now that mr
hancock has resigned
you know we need to look ahead and and
mr javed
has a huge task on his hands as dr
nagpal and others
have been saying and there's still much
to do and i hope we can just crack on
mr hancock has gone but mr johnson is
still
there now speaking for yourself as
somebody who has
i think consistently tried to support
the government in its efforts
um how are you feeling this morning
about uh
trusting the prime minister well i
always try and stay out of the politics
as you know trevor but what i would say
is that
we have had some really damning news
this week about performance uh
you know in a whole variety of ways most
importantly the national audit office
doing another review of test and trace
in england and showing that there were
still
multiple failings so i do think all
governments around the world are
struggling to deal with this pandemic
some
have done it much better than others and
i think there are big big questions
about
what's happened in the uk and we need
strong leadership at a time like this
and
there's been many unfortunate examples
so as i say i'm feeling optimistic still
about the next few weeks the vaccine
program and hopefully
vaccines will begin to impact on
transmission but as we look to the
coveted recovery
which is what all of us want to do we
need strong firm leadership that we can
trust
across all parts of the uk that's what
people living in this country deserve
professional good to talk to you as ever
the nhs in england employs around one
and a half
million people making it by some
distance the country's biggest employer
and as we've learned over the past year
it's a service that at some point
all of us could depend on to save our
lives
from that perspective there's no more
important job in the cabinet than the
health secretary
let's talk now to a man who's been there
and done it
alan johnson um is going to be
making his first appearance as hell
secretary in the next hour or so
um what do you think he should be the
first thing he does
as he sits down at his desk
get a proper briefing um about what's
going on
he has got the luxury of being appointed
at the weekend so
sometimes health secretaries and other
cabinet ministers are appointed in
you know at lunch time and then at two
o'clock have to go on to the floor of
the house of commons and stand at the
dispatch box
and act as if they are all knowing about
every issue in their department
so he's got at least got a few days i
think he's a good appointment by the way
i think you know in a cabinet of
sycophants which has been one of the
problems
he stands out because he refused to
accept the outrageous demands
placed upon him by the prime minister
and dominic cummings and
you know gave up his job as chancellor
on an issue of principle and i think
that stands him in good
stead he's got a huge uh i mean it's not
just the virus by the way the nhs is
going to go through a
huge change a beneficial change because
they're going to reverse
all the lansley reforms this is part of
the nhs plan that the government
thankfully have accepted
and go back from a system where they
were
you almost had to have a competition
lawyer in the corner every time
one hospital talked to each to another
they were going to go towards they're
going to go towards cooperation and
integration and that's a very big and
very beneficial change and it has to be
put through
uh in legislation over the coming year
you you mentioned dominic cummings and
um i'm afraid i just can't resist
um asking this uh do you have any
sympathy for
how mr cummings might feel this morning
having
in a way got rid of his nemesis he said
uh
hancock should have been sacked 15 times
last year and so on
uh and no doubt have been cheering when
hancock
went and then to find his been replaced
by the bloke
that walked rather than take cummings's
orders
it must be um a bit disappointing for
him
and absolutely no sympathy for dominic
cummings at all and neither would he
require
people you know what he said about
matt hancock's failings are all there in
a wonderful book
called failures of state by the two
sunday times insight journalist it was
published back in march
and strangely enough although it
contains every dot and comma
and much more of the disaster that was
this thing that hancock did i mean
hancock
took 15 000 people out of
uh hospitals and put them into adult
social care so he took the most
vulnerable
to this disease and placed them in the
area where they were most likely
to get it it had terrible terrible
consequences
hancock's point was that he told the
prime minister that it had all been
uh done safely or whatever it was but
but read the book failures of state it
shows how there were absolutely no
safeguards all the regulations were
suspended
for this mass migration of elderly
people
out of hospitals and into adult social
care it was a disaster and one of
many disasters in those early days that
hopefully will come out
in the um in the inquiry when it's
eventually held
we're hearing about um further let's
call them
failures of state uh this morning we are
hearing
about uh personal email accounts being
used when perhaps they should not and we
are hearing
about the inquiry which uh brandon lewis
told this program
will be mounted into how those pictures
of mr hancock uh and
his um aid were
found and of course we've now just had
news
that sensitive defense documents
were found at a bus stop in kent
home secretary health secretary this
must be the sort of nightmare
that that you you wake up sweating about
you might remember trevor because
like me you go back a long way alistair
darling getting castigated over some nhs
records
that went missing back in 2009 i think
it was and they were
treasury documents um and i hope the
same kind of castigation is going to
fall upon this government
on the first stage i could never
understand why there was a camera in the
secretary of state's office there was
never a camera in my office when i was
health secretary or in any of the other
uh five cabinet positions uh i i think
i think the rule is um that secretary
cabinet
members are not to be monitored by
anybody including
security services without express
permission of the prime minister
exactly yeah it goes back to harold
wilson's uh time
although of course our telephone
conversations there's always someone
listening in as a member of your private
office
to get a record so that you've got some
justification and some backup for
what's talked about so this private um
telephone account of matt hancock's
uh through which apparently he
negotiates some of these extremely
questionable deals for his mates to get
large
lumps of taxpayers money that's
uh that's certainly worthy uh
of investigation so there are problems
here that need to be
looked at and go beyond matt hancock but
as for matt i mean i can't you might
have covered this trevor
you i thought when this neil ferguson
issue arose
matt hancock didn't have to pile in on
neil ferguson he chose to pile in
and say that neil remember neil ferguson
had a visit from his
friend it was extraordinary behavior and
that everyone had to obey the rules and
even went so
far although the police had declared
they were not going to take any action
for this breach of law matt hancock said
if they do take action i will support
them
i mean it's talk about you know a
justified comeback
when you do that to someone a sage
advisor you know it wasn't even a
cabinet colleague someone who couldn't
really answer back
you deserve everything you get uh
johnson um
let's take it away from the person for
the moment
um what is emerging about the
culture of this department department of
health
contracts allegedly uh granted to
cronies we don't know
to what extent matt hancock was involved
in any of that but
the story is being told is that there's
cronyism
that there's a chamocracy that
email accounts are being used to keep
information away from
officials now you were there i think for
a year
a bit more than a year two years three
batman that long
okay did you get any sense
of that being the sort of underlying
culture in this department
no and i think i think you can't divorce
it from individuals i think this is a
a boris johnson style government maybe
cummings was in there as well
all this well let's wave all the rules
you know bonfire of the rules and do
what we want to do
when we want to do it i was also there
through a pandemic of course
uh it wasn't as extensive as this one
but we thought it was going to be
the return of h1n1 spanish flu that
killed
billions of people bit literally
billions back in uh
1918 it had come back and we thought it
was the big one so i saw how the nhs
operated
um and i had real admiration there's you
know the chief medical officer working
with the nhs working with the department
it's it's a it's a tricky organization
to run but there was nothing about that
organization that suggested
cronyism or or anything else until
the kind of government cronyism came in
um just very briefly ellen johnson um
how will you judge sadie javid or what
will be
the key performance indicators uh
on which you would judge him leaving
party politics aside
on whether he has been a good health
secretary or not
well i've left party politics aside to
welcome him i think he's a good
appointment
um i think he's the best possible
appointment
other than perhaps uh jonathan ashworth
under a labour government but
i think sergey getting on with his job
quietly undemonstratively
and in a measured
fashion that's what the nhs want to hear
and he's get out there amongst the nhs
they don't want
someone who's looking for headlines
every evening
and who's looking to kind of climb the
greasy pole
sarge has already done it i mean he's
held two of them are you saying that
are you talking about anybody in
particular there maybe
not me i assure you uh but that's why
you can't divulge it from the personal i
mean they've had
i mean jeremy hunt was was in many ways
a very good health secretary
in the years he did that that job i've
got my issues with him but
you know he he sort of exuded
uh confidence and and quiet
modest a quite modest approach to
politics and i think that's what sajid
will bring as well
very generous of youth alan johnson
thank you very much indeed
thanks trevor well that's it for now
after the break we'll be talking about
what we've learned on this morning's
programme with our deputy political
editor
sam coats
[Music]
you